why don't you talk about what the Super
Force is and how you believe that solves
some of the problems in quantum gravity
okay it's interesting because you can
say this would go back to Sir Isaac
Newton uh I think was
1693 I could be possibly wrong with the
year he writes a letter to his friend in
which he says what if what if gravity is
caused by an agent capital a that acts
constantly in accordance with given laws
of
nature why what if this agent capital A
is the Super Force and what I mean by
the Super Force would be like the force
of unification the force that would rule
over the other forces
and
equalize all forces I believe it does
exist at the plank scale now why at the
plank scale look carefully at the
structure of general relativity
formalism that's used by Einstein and I
shall not use Richie or remon and
curvature formalism I'll use Einstein
tensor so G sub muu equals what a 8
Pi Big G divided by C to the 4th the
whole thing times T sub muu that t sub
youu again representative energy density
but look carefully at that Scala
constant it has a termin it C to the 4th
divided by Big G well if you do the math
that term comes from a plank energy
divided by plank length
so your plank mass time c² the whole
thing divided by g h bar / C Cube the
whole thing 12 the thing comes up as C
to the 4 /
G how can you get a plank Force
featuring within general relativity and
it goes further you can find the C to
the 4th / by Big G what's I term the
Super Force this force of unification in
the dck equation which is the
relativistic form of schinger equation
the foundational form formalism of
quantum mechanics which is absolutely
remarkable that the C to the 4 / G
should figure not only that but the
Super Force equals the plank force and
the plank force does not have H bar in
it so it's non planken in nature it's
classical which means the Super Force
which equals the plank Force at the
plank scale is the bridge between the
world of the very large namely general
relativity and the world of the very
small represented by Quantum field
Theory and according to Professor J Aras
this is what's needed a force of
unification a
bridge that would unify all four known
forces in this case including gravity
even though some people think of it as
non Force they think of it as a
space-time geometric curve
but if you look carefully okay and now
that I've said what I've said with the c
c to 4 / Big G look carefully at
Einstein equation it can be reformulated
it actually saying that the super force
acting on the SpaceTime
geometric structure gives rise to energy
density hence matter and you can just
see by rearranging the terms of the
equation that that's exactly what's
saying not only that if you look
carefully at the beckenstein Hawking
formulation for entropy of a black hole
C to the 4 / Big G also features in that
because your entropy of a black hole
would be given as H bar divide or
actually uh K sub B which is the
boltzman constant divided by H Bar C
that term time C 4 / G time
your area of the black
hole that would be your entropy and you
can actually see that I am correct the
actual and the significant again is that
it is the super force acting on the area
of the black hole that generates this
black hole entropy hence I believe it's
the Super Force that's the bridge the C
to the 4 divided by Big G which is non
planken in nature acts as the bridge
between the world of the very large and
the world of the very
small and it is it exists at the plank
scale at every point in space and
time okay so help me understand what
does it mean when you say that it acts
on it so firstly let me make this clear
when you say Super Force you're
referring to the plank force and people
can look at what the plank force is yes
okay yes and then secondly when you say
it acts on it so let's imagine we have G
equal K * T and forget about G is
Einstein forget I'm just making up some
variables I could have said xal K * y I
wouldn't say k is acting on y but you're
saying K is acting on Y in that case so
what does that mean to me I see that as
a proportionality constant so as like a
conversion factor okay so think of the
analogy between the main formula of
general relativity G sub equal that
Scala constant times D subu now
transform it into dimensional
character just think of it uh would be
one / l s where your L would be some
characteristic length could be the plank
length equal um um L / e time e divided
by L cubed energy okay right right e/ L
Cub that's your energy density term
well what is a force it's a it's really
the gradient of an of an energy that's
why that e / by L it's really your Super
Force and if you just put that term on
the other side it's actually saying it's
the super force acting on your
space-time geometric curvature that
yields your energy density hence matter
so I believe it is the super force that
generates matter based on whatever that
space time geometric curvature
local in that particular domain is
so you could actually have a different
idea of what it's just remarkable what
Einstein has come up with it's it's if
if you just restructure it you see a
whole different meaning of his formula
but still and it says it is the super
force acting on the space-time geometric
structure that gives rise to energy
density hence matter that is interesting
I think it's new anyway it's just a new
way of looking it's just a new
perspective on Old
physics okay so let me state it in my
words and see if this aligns with what
you're saying yes sir okay so
traditionally in Einstein's equations
you have G which which colloquially is
space time and so geometry and then on
the right side there's T which is the
stress energy tensor which is thought of
as the matter now these are coupled but
you can think of it as geometry and then
there's some proportionality constant in
the matter now you're saying that it's 8
pi divided by the plank Force so let's
just move the plank Force to this side
so it's plank force times the geometry
equals 8 Pi * the matter distribution
you can think of the Super Force or the
plank force in this case what is the
Super Force it is the plank Force
because it acts at the plank scale so
therefore the Super Force equals the
plank Force so what that equation now
says it's the Super Force that's acting
on the SpaceTime geometric structure
that yields your tunu your energy
density which represents
matter okay I'm going to need to think
about that some more because I still
don't see so the way that I see it is
that okay cool these numbers come up in
a couple different places it comes up in
quantum mechanics and it comes up in
relativity and these are what we're
trying to merge keep in mind C to 4 /
Big G why should it come up in the D
equation by a manipulation of the terms
in the D equation or the shorting
equation and also in general relativity
and just think of it actually even
easier than that if this Force C to 4 /
Big
G why should it be non planking in a
classical realm because it is plank
energy divided by uh plank length that
all of a Sun loses its H bar term so it
becomes classical why because the Super
Force must exist and it's 10 to the 44
Newtons I believe it actually act it
acts at what um eventually going to talk
about the ashar bounce point and you can
give more in your
podcast you understand this because you
read the right yes so Astra car's bounce
what what Sal is referring to is this
paper called the robustness of key
features of quantum of loop Quantum
cosmology so people can look that up
that will be in the description you and
I both know that Fitness coaches can be
pricey thus I was thrilled when co-pilot
Fitness approached us it's not just an
app but rather it's a personalized
Fitness solution connecting you with an
affordable Real Life Fitness coach who
tailors workouts to your needs and goals
my wife and I both love our coaches in
fact and I'm not even kidding my wife is
in the background using this app right
now working out I've never been more
excited to work out and I'm not someone
who needs motivation to do so and that's
in part because my coach Rod improves my
B yes I said that no apologies co-pilot
offers personalized workouts with a
step-by-step guidance expert coaching
for support and accountability and
flexibility to work out anywhere anytime
Forbes even listed it as their top rated
personal trainer app of 2023 ready to
feel fit and fabulous give give co-pilot
a try head to go.my copilot
docomo for a 14-day free trial and 20%
off your first month of personalized
Fitness with your own personal trainer
if you sign up prior to February 1st
2024 that's go.my copilot docomo for a
14-day free trial and 20% off your first
month sign up for the new year and let
co-pilot help you reach your fitness
goals okay now you're saying this bounce
is relevant to your work because because
I'm saying it's the Super Force that
acts at the plank skills that's at this
bounce point this ashaka bounce point
that actually you can think of it as
saying thus far and no further by
actually saying there are no SpaceTime
singularities it doesn't go to zero it
goes to the spank
scale it's exactly what professor
ashar talks about when he talks about
his
bounds I believe it is the Super Force
that acts at this bounds that prevents
any so-call SpaceTime singularities from
forming this I still need to think about
some more so I'm going to be thinking
about it between now when we speak again
sure sir and please make sure that you
read that conversation I I believe it's
number three by the way three uh I like
the number three very much so go ahead
okay so just what s's referring to is
there's this book called conversations
on quantum gravity which anyone who's
interested in quantum gravity should
read and there are different chapters
and each chapter is a theoretical
physicist talking about the problem of
quantum gravity from their point of view
which generally contradicts everyone
else's point of view so it's fun to
watch because they pretty much are
squabbling without speaking to one
another and number three
zakar
yes did ball lightning inform your work
with
plasma I cannot say it did again what
informed it was was the but that's a
very good question what informed it was
this um idea of uh considering the
heavyside version of of Maxwell's
equation and this idea of that you can
get these extremely high electromagnetic
energy fluxes but if you look carefully
at at his question it's quite possible
that that's why it works that's why for
example it's very unusual that these uh
these effects can these balls of plasma
can actually go through solid walls you
have to question
why
how you hear people talk about orbs in
the UFO circles do you believe these to
be related to ball lightning or some
form of
plasma I quite believe that there are
forms of plasma yes sir it speaks it
speaks to this idea of quantum
electrodynamic vacuum breakdown because
once you achieve these effects all these
anomalies can be present yes I do
believe that's
possible just to get a bit speculative
here these balls are usually of the size
of order of a tennis ball to a
basketball they're generally not larger
than a building let's say so let's speak
on the ones that are small do you
imagine that to be a small craft a
probe hypers speculation again this is
okay the from a hypers speculation point
of view I would say it's quite possible
these are
probes
yes when someone is operating in that
craft that you outlined in this hybrid
craft using an inertial maths hybrid
craft using an inertial Mass
modification
device article are you able to control
the craft from within it because in some
of these SpaceTime engineer I know
you're not engineering the metric but in
some of these craft which depend on
space time metric engineering it's not
as if you can control the mechanism that
propels you forward so that you can stop
it and move it left and right and so on
because it's causally disconnected from
you can you control it in your
model I believe it's possible again
refer to froning's work and the
condition vacuum once you can achieve
these voids within the vacuum it's quite
possible possible that you can uh affect
these uh think of the craft as being
sucked Within These voids within the
vacuum that are created that's what
Froning work talks
to and you can see his work you can I I
believe it uh there PDFs of it still
available on uh if you Google them
yeah Dr lachno or I don't know how to
pronounce it but Dr LNO oh Victor LNO
yeah Dr LNO said or at least seemed to
be one of the few that spoke positively
about your work in Academia okay so can
you speak about what his thoughts
were he believes that I'm able to
generate uh B iin condensate like states
whereby it is possible for these uh uh
room temperature high temperature
superconductive effects to be achieved
and uh I believe Dr LNO again
uh he I'm not sure he could be of
Ukrainian origin but I'm not sure let's
explain what a b Einstein condensate is
and then as well as what a
superconductor
is
uh what's the difference between the two
okay
um I wouldn't call myself a good explan
I I could not provide a good explanation
of of exactly what a b Einstein
condensate is all all I could say is
that in a superconductor you can achieve
Cooper pairing so you can so you can
actually have your electrons uh somehow
couple with one another so now they
actually can move smoothly through your
conductor rather than uh now exactly how
this is done because after all between
two electrons you have uh a repulsion
for force a very high repulsion Force so
exactly how this is done within a
superconductor this is uh the idea of
BCS Theory I think bardine Koop and
shrier they also got the Nobel Prize for
uh hi for
uh so for superconductivity I
believe but it was not
um high temperature superconductivity
now Professor LNO says it is possible to
generate these B Einstein
condensate I I believe these are states
of matter when you go very extremely low
in temperatures you you can actually
have uh coupling between your electrons
for example the this whole idea of of
coopa pairing how these electrons couple
to one another so they actually move as
one uh I
believe what vulang K Professor K who's
uh who received the Nobel Prize for uh
the Practical achievement of a Bose
Einstein condensate the best way to
refer to it is to have these electrons
move as if they March in lock step where
one giant matter wave he called it yes I
have great respect for Professor k